- 18?
NO.
[inspirational music]
♪ ♪
- I'M FINALLY HOME.
[moaning]
- SOMETHING ISN'T RIGHT.
THIS IS THE ROOM...
BUT IT'S NOT THE ROOM.
DID THEY MOVE THE WALLS?
NOPE.
THAT'D BE PHYSICALLY IMPOSSIBLE.
[grunting]
[screaming]
UH, NO.
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
IN ORDER FOR SEMEN SPRAY
TO LAND HERE
THE BUSTER WOULD HAVE
TO SHOOT FROM HERE.
BUT ERIC WAS OVER THERE.
AND HE DIDN'T EVEN BUST.
WAS THERE A SECOND
SEMEN SPRAYER?
NO.
NOPE.
START FROM THE BEGINNING, ADAM.
- WHO THE [bleep] ARE YOU?
- IS THIS WHERE THE PORNO WAS?
- I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, MAN.
JUST--JUST GET OUT OF HERE.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
I BELIEVE YOU.
I DON'T SEE PORNO IN YOUR EYES.
SORRY, I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO LOOK AROUND FIRST.
FEMALE SEX.